chaque jour est un jour de bonheur pour
toi c'est vrai bah nouvelles tous les
jours je relaxe ne sais pas si c'est une
[Rires]
bruno et mathieu surtout mathieu mathieu
a craqué sur toi tu as dit que tu es
célibataire ouais tu chies nom d'
atteinte à un fiancé avant il ya
longtemps déjà une histoire d'amour ce
fut un moment que ça s'est terminé alors
là tu cherches quoi tu cherche l'amour
quand as tu cherches mais tu sais que
l'amour trappe à ta porte quand tu te
tais à temps plein c'est vrai ça n'a
rien à voir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est vrai où l'amour c'est pas
comme le facteur site ouvre pas une fois
l'amour
peut-être le jour à ne pas repasser non
mr 10 à faire un ace mais non mais très
ému de revoir bruno alors
tout en gardant un instant oui parce que
j'ai quelque chose à lui déjà alors on
va on va le savoir
mathieu oui hier vous avez eu un
véritable coup de foudre pour beaune
bon je réponds non ah oui ou non j'ai eu
j'ai eu j'ai passé c'est une rencontre
qu'on appelle ça t'as craqué états unis
au moment où
le problème que j'ai avec vous c'est que
comme on dire aux états unis j'ai
l'impression que j'avais un lot of money
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est
ce que oui
ou c'est un moment quand même parce que
sinon aux pruneaux et est pas là pour ça
ah oui les perles pas parler pour lui
mais c'était un mot men particulier
parce que c'est quand tu sens qu'il se
passe quelque chose mais que c'est c'est
réceptif
tu sens qu'il ya quelque chose ni
combien fut il ya un fluide il ya
quelque chose par exemple c'est tout
bête tu donnes un exemple mais je
m'approche un tout petit peu mais ma
caméra
dites moi si je me trompe ses besoins
personnels c'est vrai voilà
eric sentant l'abandon
[Applaudissements]
ça passe de leurs actifs
écoutez même pas que cela passe par le
lff active
c'est bon elle est là que ça devient
mature déjà il a reconnu votre parfum
c'est très fort et voilà alors est ce
arrivé on sait où en tout cas on a
trouvé votre reconversion il ya un
marionnaud sephora
[Rires]
bruno et mathieu tirons nous rejoignent
et à 19h47 en direct se sont rencontrés
hier sur ce plateau moi je suivais bruno
puisque je regarde les 12 coups de midi
parce que je suis fan de jean luc déjà
et je suis très vite devenu fan de bruno
et bruno moi je vous aimais sans arrière
pensée
c'est que vous êtes beau vous êtes riche
mais je ne vous aime pas pour sa 11ème
pour votre personne avec un grand p
comme pantagruel
bon jeu rapide
mathieu mais qu'est ce qui vous a plu
chez bruno
alors tout il est beau gosse mais des
beaux gosses on en croise beaucoup oui
mais d'abord il est extrêmement brillant
extrêmement cultivé savent véritablement
ça vraiment cessé c'est très sensuel
c'est quand on est en face de quelqu'un
ou à l'arbre dîne avec on apprend plus
de choses il est brillant il est
intelligent il a du charisme alors vous
vous aimez vous avez des garçons
intelligents aussi oui c'est seulement
trois questions comme ça qui me
qui a écrit
qui écrit là pour m'aider
facile qu écrit madame bovary à la base
il est elle est à
paris
madame bovary oui c'est pas mal bovary
non
non c'est mais tu sais oui il connaît ça
avec l'émotion des crimes fait que ces
crimes ne restent ouverts gustave
flaubert bien voilà est ce que vous
pouvez me donner la capitale du canada à
ottawa mais à bord il y avait quelques
années mais alors rien désolé il ya des
gentils vidant fox a pas que la
4g les volets et pas mal et attention
racine carrée
64,8 bravo
mais bon deux sur trois voyages il est
bon sur les chiffres les voyages qu'elle
aime l'oseille
est-ce que je côtoie des mineurs alors
d'abord qu'est-ce qui vous a plu chez
bruno fou terminé alain vraiment ça
parce qu'en fait j'ai souvent joué le
jeu s'ouvre il ya des gagnants je vois
même chez nagui tous ceux qui t'ont 50
60 mais ça peut il encore là je ne vois
pas ça nissan ça ne s'explique pas une
présence un charisme voilà il a ça il a
une présence il a un charisme et des
très intelligent il a l'air assez
humbles hilaire la tête sur les épaules
il est beau mais mais il a un très joli
regard très important le regard ouais
alors je ne regarde four base
est là très inégal il a un très joli
sourire et comment il est à la
télévision
et je suis sûr il est très généreux en
plus ce
match ouais est-ce que et vous me
répondez droit dans les yeux très basse
est ce que vous êtes une personne ouais
intéressée par l'argent l'oseille
et pépette bah oui
tu sais cyril
je ne sais pas si ce québec sq plus
question
sur cette photo qui la pause on a admis
en ça que j'ai laissé ma question c'est
moi qui la pause abonnés ce que ne
serait ce qu'une fois où il est paré
d'argent oui oui 6 non pas une fois
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la question de mathieu cyr il est ce que
ne serait ce qu'une fois je ne devrais
pas parler d'argent
donc tu aimes ou tu es prêt à mettre ce
côté ville mais bien sûr on comptait 1
pour la mosquée mais bien sûr j'espère
qu'il donnera tout son argent à sa
famille à ses amis à ses proches
et voilà et quoi qu'ils aient gagné un
million ça n'entre pas dans les
considérations c'est un blague
mais si je me suis un peu tombé amoureux
que des personnes peuvent
être sincère et d'être amoureux de
quelqu'un kherici plus rien ça m'avait
déjà fait ça avec vous j'ai terminé
rien concentrez vous sur bruno
bruno maintenant vous me le rappeler je
suis pas ton dès son entame autres
personnes thomas
bruno oui des gens quand merci une fois
d'être l'armée bien si on vous a fait un
questionnaire serré répondu aux
questions oui j'avais pas compris
pourquoi alors
[Rires]
c'est que vous n'avez pas compris que
j'étais là surprise de mathieu c'est
vrai gbagbo m'a dit on a fait des supers
chiffré hier tout le monde a adoré vient
faire un débrief donc j'arrive avec un
chat non c'est pas vrai non mais c'est
vrai il ya quelqu'un qui me posent des
questions tu préfères à aller au vip de
saint tropez
m
la femme sans müller
et
c'est
vraiment un c'est un amour vous voyez
pas les v6 est comme ça il m'a bien je
n'ai pas du tout revenu pour moi ben
maintenant que je sais oui mais alors
pas du tout mais en fait on loge il y
avait le retour il y avait marqué un
admirateur secret de mathieu lui fut une
surprise et du coup de demander aux gens
ce sera qui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
admirateur secret d'antenne à chaque
minute
mais attend ce que tu fais le choix tout
ça dans lequel cette évidence et tétouan
en fait mieux c'est sûr que mathieu est
très sympa alors attention bien tu le
sais tu n'auras qu'à répondre à cette
question tu as répondu c'est vrai la
première question en mars il répond la
même chose que toi c'est un petit peu
comme dans les z'amours et non pas les
zemmour qui sont beaucoup plus agressifs
[Applaudissements]
la soirée idéale en couple pour vous
j'aime bien la souris des halles en
couple pour vous mathieu oui c'est
before on vip room de saint tropez
fiesta au méga macumba de bordeaux et
after au touche-à-tout à château s'est
collé serré toute la soirée sous un
plaid à regarder l'a redit des mystères
de l'amour ce thème c'est pas mal ça non
je crois que sans hésiter c'est un jeu
c'est pas pour toi
c'est collé serré collés serrés ou le
tai chi est cadencé prépare donc en août
et calais ouais d'accord
quoi il a répondu non a répondu didier
lépine room et touche-à-tout à saintes
ou achat tout bas mais la loi est une
mauvaise réponse
je suis très que bing j'aime beaucoup
les boîtes de nuit oui c'est là ça nous
permet de connaître boon ou alors c'est
vrai quoi toi tu es plus aux attentes
n'a pas tort chaque week end boîte de
nuit avec mes amis mais l'actuel vip
room de saint tropez match on iran
somptueux à baby jane aviv a montré avec
me dire à quoi peut les faire entrer
andré
je pense qu'il est plus connue vous
oui à la franchement oui ah non je crois
pas non j'aime beaucoup
ça donne ça j'avoue mais non quand même
s'annoncer genre que c'est un ami ben
ouais bah écoute en tout cas va pas
rentrer d'ailleurs je pense que j'en
change je pense que si vous arrivez vous
pouvez le faire sortir et non par an
alors donc oui vous êtes plus érythème
dans la famille à web en tant qu agent
donc c'est pas fidèle
pendant un an j'ai tu bois de l'alcool
et ou saturne faire craquer la voiture
entre eux seuls bah oui la dynamique de
la musique oui elle est entre amis
s'amuser sur un mur entre et ouais si
toi tu aimes pas là dedans c'est
pourquoi les
enseignes à bas donc fidèle tous les
deux parfaits
qena que je crois plus que l'eau
vraie fidélité non non il est devenu
très très vite et nous voilà la wii
depuis non mais depuis qu'il a fait ou
si les faits d'abus sur un chien
avec l'argent vous êtes plutôt c'est
secondaire la richesse du coeur n'a pas
de prix - cm 1 centimes c'est comme pour
la caille chaque centimètre comptes
n'ont pas vraiment à la rue c'est pour
moi la seule richesse c'est vraiment la
richesse du coeur
[Applaudissements]
c'est que j'ai plus de plaisir à offrir
qu'à recevoir
la région plus je suis commencé à chacun
ses défauts alors et brunoy répondu la
même chose que vous la richesse du
camion n'a pas de prix c'est vrai ou non
c'est vrai la richesse du lait on n'a
pas de prix louis mais c'est bizarre
parce que tout à l'heure je regardais le
6 à 7 oui j'ai l'impression qu'il y
avait un classement des plus radin oui
c'était de leurs mots car il
était notre émission mehdaoui
juste hier c'était avant vous n'aimez
pas les mecs radin non mais je me
rappelle de la glotte de kelly qui dit
qu'a priori au resto et demande à être
invitée parce qu'il est juif et des
notes de frais c'est ça pour qu'on lui
rembourse à emménager kelly est
souffrante elle dit
[Applaudissements]
ça
mais c'est important la tâche générosité
après on n'est pas obligé de tout
dilapidé mais si à chaque fois qu'il ya
un resto c'est toujours la même personne
qui paye sa tâche passé vous allez venir
plus tôt j lire le voilà oui mais on est
pas un homme d'argent oui c'est ça on
compte pas mais on partage quoi je
rentrais à la maison assure qu comptez
pas sur lui pour partager c'est clair en
amour vous êtes mathieu comme une
formule 1 tout va vite même trop vite et
tant pis si on fait une sortie de piste
ou comme un vélib on prend son temps
découvre le paysage dans le regard de
l'autre et on choisit une selle bien
confortable
s'est voulue question
non je dirais que tout va vite tout va
vite mais on peut aller très vite sans
faire de sortie de route album j'en
avais répondu la même chose
on s'embrasse à me moquer monnaie
cette barrière quant
à lui en vue de la levée la barre
[Rires]
seul passage à niveau là d'être acquis
mon passé
bruno toi tu aimes tu aimes bien white
and apte à retourner au feu va trop vite
ça c'est des coups de foudre c'est ça
m'a vite ça disons qu'en fait je
m'attache pas beaucoup mais du coup dès
que ça marche bien avec quelqu'un cette
tendance en effet à ce que ça aille très
vite s'il suit c'est bon je suis plus
tout jeune non plus donc il faut que
les magnifiques lettres qu'elle a dit oh
toi peut encore s'en tiennent des entre
temps si tu fait les bons choix
quatrième question votre conjoint fauté
quelle est votre réaction vous pardonner
parce que c'est comme au restaurant
saussez n'est pas trompé
[Rires]
vous n'êtes pas de l'est pas ce qui est
arrivé une fois peut t'arriver quatre
fois regarde casta
question et si
vous répondez quoi non je ne pardonne
pas et pas un qui vole une pomme vol 2
tab
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le groupe est à peu près d'accord
ou non dit la même chose une part de
bart appartenait pas mais moi je suis
très romantique et présuppose que quand
on est à fond avec quelqu'un ne
serait-ce que l'idée de vouloir aller
sérieures regardez l'affairé l'animal
prend mes mots c'est pareil non mais
c'est vrai quand vous êtes sur une route
vous regardez pas là les voitures qui
passent à côté et non c'est là le
message c'est de bison futé
donc bruno principal attention pas mal
j'avais trois réflexes produit une
erreur une dernière question les
bouleversants le surnom qui aurait pu
vous donner votre ex c'est le soldat
toujours au garde-à-vous prêt à dégainer
son fusil
[Applaudissements]
magazine
c'est des images vous
comprenez pas la poésie c'est
koné lui allait bien c'était mon garde
voilà le soldat toujours regard d'amour
prêt à dégainer son fusil et quitte à se
retrouver à court de munitions au caire
[Rires]
le violoniste vous maniez votre
archevêque de
la légende raconte que vous êtes capable
de jouer un concerto pour qu'une fausse
tiers
mais plutôt quoi alors en vrai ça je
dois reconnaître que
je suis plutôt le le premier soldat et
le soldat sauf que je suis pas à court
de munitions ma poule mais c'est
bon je pleurais pas là pour parler
chasse
musique on astique merci
[Rires]
non a répondu la réponse b le violoniste
a
[Applaudissements]
assez complémentaires je te rassure que
les questions comme la pause était
formulée comme ça
j'avais loupé de loi m
mathieu ouais il est temps maintenant de
faire son choix mais pardon vous oubliez
milliers de questions très simples quoi
est-ce que physiquement je lui plais sam
attendait il s'en va le maire et toutes
les questions après on encore une heure
et demie d'émission
a pas de débat maman tu ça va arriver
c'est bon
de toit et les jantes sa radio ouais
est ce que pour l'instant un êtes
conquis par toutes les réponses de bruno
et tout ce qu'il a dit tout ce qu'il a
tout ce qui est relié à personne alors
sert il oui cyril je suis totalement
conquis
c'est beau à l'émouvant
matthieu delormeau
qui cherche l'amour de vata pas froid
[Musique]
[Rires]
il n'a pas froid c'est cute matthieu
delormeau qui cherche l'amour et
matthieu delormeau et eu la chance
de rencontrer hier sur ce plateau
des champions
que champion des 12 coups de midi
bruno
renaud est à la tête
une petite sortie
respect d'un million d'euros
mais mathieu
n'ai pas les os rookie c'est juste
rejoindre celui qu'ils considèrent comme
son héros
mathieu
j'aimerais maintenant que les masques
tombent
et qu'au delà de cette mascarade
ce jeu de ce spectacle
[Musique]
l'amour
- son petit musée
[Rires]
jusqu'au bout mathieu gel à voir les
derniers mots pour convaincre bruno que
vous êtes la personne qui lui faut et
bruno répondra aux bruno repartir à seul
avec son chèque oui il repartira avec
son chèque
et son talon de chèque
[Rires]
le roi de la dynastie des delormeau
1962 où il va
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mathieu
un dernier mot pour mot non
non je crois que c'est tout dit mais
c'est pas la peine d'avoir mal à faire
la voix johnny
ont été plus autres au scan ah oui c'est
ce chemin
alors il essaie de vous montrer tous ces
talents
non non non ce qui est beau dans la vie
c'est que on choisit tout sauf
l'essentiel
j'ai passé par on choisit pas ce
soit dit pas non plus des trottoirs de
manier le manuel
c'est sa carrière tu arrivé dans cette
émission pour parler de tongs un
ignorant qu en réalité le véritable gain
que tu allais trouvé bien c'est mal
tombé gardé l'amour voilà y'a qu'une
petite chose et je te dis franchement
qui pourrait être compliqué pour toi mon
jara ensemble c'est oui c'est difficile
de vivre avec une célébrité
[Rires]
lorsque les gens viennent vers quelqu'un
parce qu'on peut ignorer mais je te
rendrai légitime tu sauras les gt1 ce
que tu sera mien
tiens voilà l'habitat bien nous voilà
une fichiers
donc votre proposition de vie banon
millions ça un petit peu long en a mais
je sais où il habite on s'est parlé
pendant la pub mais alors n'aurait rien
eu le besoin
[Rires]
d'apporter de la proposition de vis et
je te dire quelque chose
la cour a ceci de particulier c'est que
ça ne se passe jamais comme on l'a
planifiée ne planifions rien la vie
c'est ici et maintenant ici on fait une
chanson ça
ça vous dit quelque chose de beau te
ramène une mère d'ingrid
couple c'est maintenant c'est une
chanson déjà c'est à bassila bon alors
et donc voila voila est terminée
oublions ou vision c'est que vous l'avez
regardé dans les 12 coups de midi jeu
sur wii menteur flégeau jurés vous
messieurs crachements ne me dérangeait
rien à vous jurés ont entendu parler à
lui c'est lui que je suis bien c'est pas
vous coûter quand j'aurais pu mieux vaut
prendre bam
[Applaudissements]
donc pour terminer
n'oublions oublions de la bêtise de
l'âge je serai ton rené tu seras masse
est
comme le titanic
[Rires]
ou non
toutes les cartes sont entre tes mains
c'est le moment as-tu des as
as tu des joker ou à tous les deux et
trois et cartes dégueulasse
oh non
est ce que ton aventure télévisuelle a
été un moment exceptionnel pour toi je
crois que oui c'est incroyable
incroyable
aujourd'hui
phuket ce n'est que le prolongement de
ta vie
la télé tout rapporter l'argent
la télé en vie d'aujourd'hui t'apporter
l'amour
déjà est-ce que mathieu te plais
physiquement
février en plus pour son âge franchement
[Applaudissements]
mais ces lois aussi vers les 50 ans
avec berkat plus des cinq mois ça comme
à miyagi vois ça comme un professeur
bassa comme un chemin mais tellement un
maquereau miyagi yaghi tobback samia
guerrilla games est terminé dit donc
vous allez rater qui guident alors donc
énorme donc physiquement ça c'est
physiquement il s'en sort très bien s'en
sort bien c'est à dire c'est pas tout à
fait ton style bof non mais dans sa cour
et ça pourrait s'il n'y a pas de veto là
dessus mais tel qu'il
dit pas vous ne
dites pas veto et s'ordonne ya de nadal
ce qui est veto sa patte
sinon l'histoire ne tiendra pas
d'accord jamais jamais jamais jamais
alors dont alain vous n'y a pas de
contrat ni contre indications par contre
j'ai pas la référence sur move donc non
mais ça n'a pas été déprogrammé s'était
inscrit à sept ans sans fondement solide
qui lie les missiles animer une émission
en prime time sur nrj avec sa playbook
je suis passé à côté
qui a été un carton sur les caniches de
moins de droits
[Applaudissements]
c'est très très peur sur cible
bruno
montcoudiol non plus ça passe oui ça va
est ce que je tombe et harchaoui est-ce
que intellectuellement comme intelligent
oups
sur une échelle de 1 à 10 bah ça c'est
dur de voir comme ça mais on voit tout
de suite à cette intervention doit ce
que je dis à chaque fois le coeur tu le
regardes en tout cas là son discours
assez poétique était assez bien fait
assez drôle
donc c'est peut-être pas le plus
intelligent autour de la table
[Rires]
il dit
maintenant vous voici une très belle
soirée
non mais je veux dire il ya des
personnes passant que géraldine on voit
tout de suite que les classes du niveau
est aussi d'accord et lui je tends
meilleur surtout
[Applaudissements]
il est pas très intelligent on respecte
le maquereau des mairies là mais d'une
star manu mannequin et tchéquie moi
désolé pour nos missionnaires du genre
et passe de connaître les sujets en
discutant se rendrait compte que
titulaire est-ce que tu trouves qu'est
ce que tu aimes admirez donc en campagne
oui bah oui toute façon du moment que tu
es amoureux quoi qu'il arrive tu admires
admirer l adversaire t'admire matthieu
delormeau tu veux qu'on voit un extrait
du
cénotaphe à ce moment-là ça c'est pas
bien au même salaire alors est-ce que tu
admires tout compagnon alors mathieu n'y
a pas grand monde que j'admire comme ça
au quotidien mais si quelque chose se
crée oui j'admire vraiment mais la
laisse que tout était têtue l'admirer
avant de le connaître un peu femme est
enceinte sur le connaissais pas
spécialement
non mais surface alors malgré cette
affaire
beaucoup d'émissions tu m'as vu déjà vu
quand même quelques belles je savais
qu'il s'était absolument
non
[Rires]
croit que c'est le moment prendre une
décision
bono tu fais toujours célibataire oui
est-ce que tu as quelqu'un en ligne de
mire à barr mathieu sa part mathieu
n'ont pas spécialement la personne
vraiment à personne en fait non je suis
libre parce que tu as dû être
extrêmement sollicités
faire est addict était célibataire à la
télévision et c'est vrai que tu est
extrêmement beaux cap a beaucoup de
qualités il est intelligent il est
intelligent il est sympathique il est
souriant et les ans de la graine c'est
très sollicités aussi oh là là où
il est seul
bruno très beaucoup de sollicitations
oui mais pas tant que ça ou alors je
passe vraiment à côté mais
toléré et accessible assez pour sa part
ses membres et ils osent pas les gens
bah si tu leur dis tout ce tandem
habilités ou là mais il va pas partir
avec un dépressif ou plus
c'est vrai il a tout pour lui veut pas
partir avec un dépressif a donc calmé
vous revenez à à ce que l'essentiel de 2
de votre personnalité c'est à dire le
rire bardot maître nerfs est bonne mais
le souci bon bah c'est bon
bruno oui
ma question est simple
elle est vraiment très sympa qui est ce
que si éventuellement tu pouvais
peut-être ou pas beaucoup d'adversaire
repartir avec une personne susnommé
matthieu delormeau
a surtout nommé pas suisse
[Rires]
ce que tu serais enclin
à te rapprocher de cette personne
extrêmement médiatisé
est extrêmement vous dire belle dans sa
tête sans son coeur et dans son slip
ça laisse à la normale
ça fait rêver c'est bon maintenant c'est
le moment ouais c'est toujours le moment
de répondre bono
tu vas nous dira d'abord
ta réponse est ton argument bien entendu
la réponse aller simple c'est oui c'est
non
ou c'est
toi qui es tu me
parles avec strange
world in progress alors oui ou non non
ce serait mieux la réponse à après
l'argument donc une facture on t'as
demandé quelque chose
il n'a pas tort alors dit nous d'abord
saïd et après tu me donnes un
tableau de mathieu avec un grand m quand
même
c'est vrai que physiquement il est très
bien progressé
il est sûrement très gentil très
sympathique il a montré qu'ils pouvaient
être drôle avoir de l'esprit donc je
suis sûr que c'est un homme qui a
beaucoup de qualités paraît
beaucoup de qualités tu veux parler de 2
quad et de qualités de coeur de coeur
même du sang est ce que c'est quelqu'un
tu sens sincère alors
[Rires]
c'est pas le mot que j'ai aurait utilisé
ses recherches la confiance moi ça ça
laisse à quelque chose de naturel de
simples
être pas les mots qui définissent
mathieu naturel simple
alors c'est pas non plus quelqu'un de
traître non non non non non il est
franchement tu peux avoir confiance en
lui ah oui je suis un paysan mentionné
des
pv et les pieds dans la boue terre j'ai
déjà la notion d affaires oui on a je
deviens une famille que je suis en klaus
va coûter mon univers et arrêta connard
[Applaudissements]
et gerland des paysans et votre mère et
les avocats pour des poules
il était avocat pour des paysans
d'accord
parce que j'avais 10 ans on a confiance
en eux exact non mais c'est vrai voilà
c'est dit on dit mais il vrai père sur
la valeur et vous vous il terminer comme
ça absolument et d'endettement et donc
donc une personne qui est sincère qui a
les pieds sur terre c'est ce qu'elle
veut qui sait ce qu'elle ne veut plus
est ce qu'elle veut c'est quoi c'est la
sincérité et l'amour le reste q soit
beau qu'ils soient riches ou
assez de la poudre voilà ça c'est là
pourtant qu'est ce qu'on s'en fiche on
s'en fiche s'en fiche et quand bien même
son check in tehran on on ne partagerait
pas ou si peu
[Rires]
la gale
et faire d'avoir un petit tour de table
qui croient en cette histoire c'est oui
ou c'est non beinheim c'est non c'est
non benjamin castaldi non sur quoi
pourquoi dit on manque de confiance mais
ça non mais parce que mon nom bruno je
sens qu'il a besoin de quelqu'un qui est
un peu plus dans une rectitude morale
break tutu noir ça veut dire que vous
avez avec tom
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d'abord l'image alors oui non c'est
impossible à là parce que c'est tout
l'inversé de bruno match nul il est faux
les fouilles n'est pas sincère
non ça ne pourra jamais marcher et
chauffe les opposés s'attirent on guette
surtout je ne lui conseille pas du tout
de faire ce choix
et ses impros des choix qui par
l'internaute
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais y croire parce qu'ils le
méritent mathieu puis on a besoin ça
fait longtemps qu'il est célibataire oui
ça fait longtemps ça oui dit il pour moi
c'est un grand oui
bruit s'y connait un way est bonne on a
transformé ma jument quelqu'un de bien
non ça vient ça mais chiffres ici
d'arrivée l'amour ça le touche parce que
ça ne concerne pas
isabelle moi je veux préserver bruno que
j'adore donc c'est non même s'il ne
considère pas comme une personne
intelligente que ces noms sur wii mais
dès que j'ai peut-être lecture du
journal parce que ce n'est pas du venin
c'est
là bas mais non non pas sous la dent non
c'est moche non la balle je vais me le
déstabiliser s'est rien passé on vient
de les toucher à votre qu il y aura des
verrues
bernard montiel morceaux se serait bien
passé pour tous les deux en revanche lui
veut toujours vivre je crois dans le sud
et lier un problème unisyn star à paris
va pas mentir aux gens il est vainqueur
26 c est quoi l'histoire bon je dis que
ce serait bien c'est un beau couple le
problème c'est que il veut rester dans
ces terres de c'est un paysan lui
raconta carrière pour lui et quelle
carrière
[Applaudissements]
je pense je pense qu'il peut la mettre
[Rires]
ça n'a pas changé grand chose c'est que
les gens les jeux du taux n'était pas
dollars j'ai pas été emmerdé par les
coups depuis la
bad et m'a dit c'est un casting
improbable comme ça sur papier mais
c'est parce que c'est impossible que ça
peut se faire moi je trouve que bruno
vous êtes une belle âme il n'y a pas du
tout cynisme chez vous donc c'est tout
le contraire de matthieu et donc je ne
sais pas quoi vous aimons t elle
vraiment et ils croient à bacilles sont
aimantés oui mais le nord le 6 quoi y'a
rien
peut marcher mais je vous jure quand je
vous vois comme ça tous les deux il
semble en tout cas on aurait envie qu'il
soit heureux s'est cassé toi ya
quelqu'un qui peut dire un mot gentil
alors on a envie de s'il vous plaît on a
quelqu'un quand même un petit bourg
vient directement avec des textes aux
maps et ce qu'il entend par
là une heure il était avec thomas
guard s'y connaît en amour il a vu les
étoiles
il a vu la grande ourse fait le rapport
c'est évidemment un grand nom une
réveille toi max lutins immonde crevard
la vérité alors c'est quelqu'un qui a
vécu énormément de temps en apesanteur
[Rires]
et vous tirez vous y croyez qu'est ce
que tu as à lui alors on pense que je
n'y croyais pas je ne ferai pas cette
semaine je crois encore en deux choses
dans la vie l'amour et l'oseille
l'amour et isabelle morini bosc et oui
oui et en plus beaucoup de temps à
attendre
je sais que le temps qu'elle bouge
encore
c'est vrai elle encore alerte
nous attendons tous la réponse
bruno qu'est-ce que tu décides de faire
tu décides de
dire oui mathieu je laisse une chance ou
est-ce que tu me dis non ya pas de jeu
qui peut l'être qu'est ce qu'un toit une
musique qu'il fait plutôt détendue
écoutez son envie d'avoir peur aurait
dit votre carrière
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ils seront pris
lumière
qui les tuent leur anus
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans la 5 planètes cette
émission sur les planètes
et on revient tut
[Rires]
gony décide tout de laisser une chance à
mathieu ce serait bien alors mathieu
tu attend la réponse de moyens aux
loisirs maintenant comment es-tu
confiant alors c'est
lumière causse
vitraux de l'insi
non mais le l'amour ceux-ci de
l'intelligence qui ne se définit pas et
se reconnaît et c'est vrai quand il est
venu hier
j'ai senti quelque chose sous une forme
d'évidence se senti quelque chose comme
s'ils avaient voilà un fluide je pars de
là à votre associé denain stade me dit
c'est fou j'ai senti quelque chose sur
ce plateau je lui dis moi aussi il
revient là aujourd'hui je ne crois pas
au hasard comme dizaines de familles
tiao je ne crois pas au hasard je ne
crois qu'aux rencontres mais ce n'est
pas la musique rognon pape se dit
quelque chose de botul combattu machin
bah oui
donc conclusion oui j'espère ne pas me
tromper être prétentieux mais j'en suis
fière mais je pense qu'effectivement il
est il là il ressent la même chose que
moi mais je vais me tourner leurs
moutons c'est le moment où nous
attendent on a tu va nous donner ta
réponse
sous l'eau
matthieu delormeau at il une chance à
gré plus musical c'est que la mise en
scène dramatisée grenouille
d'odyssée lunaire
[Rires]
il ya un moment il ya un truc sérieux
problèmes dans la vie n'ont jamais
c'est celle de richter
alors bruno
bruno est ce que tu laisse sa chance à
mathieu delormeau ou non c'est pas un
choix facile parce que la suite de ma
vie depuis quand même de ce choix non
mais tu étais pas obligé tu peux quand
même
vous dire la vie fait d'aventurés et
parfois il ya une aventure qui devient
aventures d'une vie
indiana jones
suis-je de 13e coup de midi métier de
sage par chat
ou non la suite au petit tour de table
que vous avez fait oui je pense que je
vais quand même suivre la vie des
personnes les plus sensés paris vos
chroniqueurs donc je suis suivre l'avis
de guillaume isabelle et benjamins qui
m'ont déconseillé de m'investir dans une
relation avec mathieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
la glissante baalbeck
j'ai envie de dire game over
non c'est terminé c'est non c'est non
merci très pudique non non non non non
il est
rapide il faut que ce soit tu écoutes
les autres tu n'as bas ils ont ce qu'ils
te connaissent le mieux me déconseille
donc été brûlés sur isabelle gounod il a
une sensibilité il sent les choses quand
on est très intelligent comme lui on
sent les choses et lui voue il a tout
sauf envie de vous sentir
mais il est sûrement très sympa paraît
vous prêteriez invoquons partageriez un
mignon avec votre conjoint ben si tu as
on a un compte courant fin je tiens à
préciser que tout à l'heure et m'a
signalé qu'il était en train d'acheter
une montre de luxe et que si jamais je
voulais participer à son nom
[Applaudissements]
mais si
les mascottes ont plutôt le masque
certaine hauteur de leurs mots merci
bruno d'arrêter